let's go over to Westeros for a little
bit your main religion there discusses
it's built around a pantheon of seven
gods do you have characters in mind that
you associate with each particular
aspect of the god characters I don't
know what do you mean when you're
writing it do you have do you see any
particular characters as embodiments
that captured the spirit of each
archetypes you know no they're not
individual people you know I in the
faith of faith of seven is loosely based
on the Roman Catholic Church of the
Middle Ages I was raised Catholic
although I'm not a practicing Catholic
any longer and you know we always had
the the Trinity is the heart of that
which as a kid I had a lot of trouble
understanding and now that I'm a
grown-up I still have electro
understanding it so there you got the
father you got the Son and the Holy
Ghost and we got one God and you know it
wait a minute wait so we have three
God's Way past Catholic they have three
no no we only have one God son the
Father the Son and the Holy Ghost that's
three that's three but they're 101 okay
so so I just couldn't read to three to
seven you know we've done God where
monotheists but he has seven aspects and
you know maiden mother Crone of course
half of it is traditional pagan Triple
Goddess that's you know I stole that
from the pagans and then I added the the
male the three male aspects to it father
a warrior and Smith and then I added the
stranger to just be strange and a little
unusual the the other the unknowable the
unthinkable there so and thus created
the seven where most of the peasants say
okay we have seven gods no no you have
one God
seven aspects and here they hear their
faces so they have seven faces in a
seven of note as one K is one yeah and
then you know it the father the father
the son is the son of the Father even
though they're the same and the Holy
Ghost
he never gets any respect we don't know
he got married pregnant at one point and
that seems to be all he ever does
periodically he delivers a message to an
angel or something like that the Holy
Ghost is like the father whistles them
up say I got another virgin we got a
pregnant dozen are saying decades of
Catholic education here school boy
education Sundays three days after
Friday all say
[Laughter]